the storms provided some help in the
battle against wildfires in the Great
Smoky Mountains of Tennessee today three
more bodies were recovered bringing the
death toll to at least seven the fires
destroyed more than 700 buildings
DeMarco Morgan is in Tennessee we are
standing in what's left of what once was
a window to this three-bedroom home now
just part of the frame still left after
wildfires destroyed the place and now
all you can see is remnants burned-out
appliances and some of the items you can
pretty much make out like this AC here
and the fireplace this home had been in
the Cogdill family for more than five
decades now if you look to my left you
can see the shed and the garage which is
also destroyed here a place that family
members say held most of their
memorabilia pieces pieces that they
cherish they also told us that the fire
actually started far behind us at this
mountain here it's the locals call it
the Falls and quickly spread over the
highway to where we are now it is a
devastating loss
Anthony DeMarco Morgan thanks to Marco